when Franklin D Roosevelt signed the
Social Security Act in August of 1935 he
hoped that he could offer millions of
elderly retirees a safety net
however today Social Security pays out
more than it takes in and costs an
eye-watering one trillion dollars every
single year just to run in fact nearly a
quarter of every single tax dollar goes
towards paying Social Security this
would all be bearable if Social Security
at least took care of the elderly as it
promised but Social Security is quite
possibly the worst investment one can
make as it doesn't even give back what
one puts in so here's why Social
Security is the biggest scam in US
history
[Music]
before we dive into why social security
is a horrible investment let's first
take a look at the state of the program
itself for many decades now funding
Social Security itself has not been an
issue we did see some Social Security
benefit cuts as well as higher taxes
during the Carter and Reagan
presidencies in the late 1970's and
early 1980s in the early days and for
the past couple of decades solo security
has actually been profitable but instead
of investing in growing this money to
pay out beneficiaries in the future this
profit was loaned out to other
government sectors for decades this
wasn't a problem but as the baby boomer
generation is retiring we are seeing a
large influx of beneficiaries and a
sharp reduction in contributors to the
fund the Crump administration has
confirmed that at today's burn rate
Social Security benefits will have to be
cut at around 2035 unless of course
Social Security taxes are raised even
more but more importantly Social
Security has been stealing money from
citizens for decades as it usually
doesn't even pay back what was put in
wait a minute I thought we just
discussed that Social Security has been
paying out more than it's taking in so
how could this also be true well here's
the thing the way Social Security works
is that people who are working today are
essentially paying for the Social
Security checks of the current senior
citizens and when these guys with her
younger generation will pay for their
checks
the problem is a recent influx of Social
Security beneficiaries which now stands
at 64 million people this shouldn't be a
problem if the funds were managed well
over the past few decades as the excess
funds collected back then should easily
be able to pay back these retirees but
as this was not the case not only is all
security money being drained at a pace
where benefits will be slashed but also
these beneficiaries are not even getting
back what they put in in fact the
Heritage Foundation found that the
average beneficiary received a solid
negative annual return of negative 0.04
percent
the negative 14.5 3% so essentially the
average person would receive about how
much they put in over 40 years at best
or lose up to 15% per year even getting
back your full investment is terrible as
Social Security is not cheap Social
Security tax is an unexceptionable tax
for basically everyone yes
Social Security tax does not apply
passed one hundred thirty seven thousand
dollars per year and for government
employees but that's because government
employees have a government pension
plans which are basically the same thing
this is not the issue though the issue
is that even minimum wage workers are
required to pay 6.2 percent of their
income to Social Security and that's
just a worker side of it the company
also has to pay 6.2 percent of course
the company is just going to pay
employees less to make up for that
so really Social Security cost an
average person twelve point four percent
of their gross income every single year
and that's a big deal especially to
low-income families this makes no sense
as a big portion of people don't even
have to pay income taxes the average
American household making about sixty
thousand dollars a year for forty years
will end up contributing about $300,000
of Social Security and I forgot to
mention
Social Security checks are eligible for
income tax one paid out but even if you
get your full $300,000 back considering
that your average account balance was
$150,000 over 40 years you lost two
hundred and fifty two thousand dollars
inflation even at an inflation rate of
2.5 percent which is well below the
average of three point two two percent
in which case you would have lost three
hundred and seventy eight thousand
dollars and that's just inflation what
about lost potential even a modest
returns at five percent per year with an
average of 150 thousand dollars invested
over forty years you would have 1.0 five
million dollars at retirement with
average returns of seven percent you
have had to point to four million
dollars and with the great returns of
10% you could have had six point eight
million dollars so Social Security is
robbing millions of dollars from the
average person but I get it
now everyone is looking to invest and
grow their money and many people would
like the idea of Social Security
withholding some money for their
retirement but the problem is that this
is promoting bad savings practices as a
many fully rely on Social Security for
retirement in fact 33 percent of
Americans have saved nothing for
retirement and that was definitely not
what the program was created for Social
Security was built as a safety net
during retirement not to be the
retirement plan itself and that's
exactly the problem see the government
defaulting on Social Security payments
is not a problem as I'm sure the
government will just print more money or
take out more loans to pay the checks
but do we really want Social Security
and check trillions into the economy or
take out trillions more in loans are we
okay with Social Security forcing
everyone to pay twelve point four
percent of their paycheck to Social
Security tax and are we okay with
costing everyone hundreds of thousands
of dollars in inflation related losses
and why savers and investors millions
Social Security was created in a time
period where tens of millions of people
lost their entire life savings to the
Great Depression so helping out the
elderly was the right thing to do
despite the program being inefficient
but in a time where over a quarter of
American households are making six
figures in the middle class is doing
better than ever before
forced participation in a program that
at best this retains a numerical value
of one's money is in my opinion a scam
but that's just what I think
drop a like if you agree and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one